are we talking medically or you know
just you know jittery uh I think doctors
say one or two cups a day is fine
um so I think one or two cups a day is
fine but if you need a coffee every hour
I mean you know how coffee works right
it lifts you up but it drops you off
lower than Baseline so then it lifts you
up and drops you off lower the Baseline
and so you keep having crashes and so if
you have too much coffee you actually
end the day more exhausted
um you know I kind of nurse a cup all
day I actually like coffee on the
weekends believe it or not because I
like the taste of it weirdly drink more
coffee on the weekends but you know one
or two cups a day